(soft music)
Dr. Garry is coming back.
He is going to be delivering
the fourth of his four lectures.
But with that I'm gonna turn it over to Joe
as we take a look at some pediatric orthopedic issues.
Great.
So as we look at pediatric orthopedic issues,
we're gonna talk about some of the more common
in the pediatric orthopedic world.
A lots of most common, okay.
They might not be common in our world,
they're common in their world
and we need to know about them.
We're gonna talk about intoeing the apophysitis
and then we're gonna talk a little bit
about complications of obesity.
I wanna bring this to your attention.
This is PGALS, pediatric gait, arm, leg, and spine.
And it's really a great screening test or tool.
This is not gonna be on the exam. I haven't seen it.
It's not old, but it's been around for 15 plus years.
But it is really a great tool to utilize.
You can Google it, take a look at the video.
It literally takes about two minutes to do your screening,
musculoskeletal exam with it.
And then Dr. Foster has developed submodules.
So you know, if my knee exam is abnormal,
then I have a submodule that I can do for my knee.
If my shoulder exam or my spine exam is abnormal,
I've got these submodules.
So it's really very helpful to use and utilize.
And once you use it three or four times in your practice,
you'll get it and it will all be pretty automatic.
We're gonna start by talking about
Duchenne's muscular dystrophy,
because this is the most common fatal disease
affecting children.
Typically males who are affected.
Onset is usually around that five to six year age range
when they start becoming a little bit more clumsy.
They may fall a little bit more.
They develop that calf pseudo hypertrophy that can occur.
And it takes a while to make this diagnosis
because it's not something
that we oftentimes think about upfront.
A lot of times, we just reassure them,
well, you know, Johnny or Susie or whatever
may be a little clumsy, and that may be it,
you know, let's see how it plays out over time.
You know, it could be three or four months later
when they come in,
they basically look normal on their exam,
particularly if we don't get them completely undressed.
To be able to look and kind of pay attention to the calf,
because the calf is, a lot of times what you'll see first
or earliest in this.
You know, now with with new developments,
prognosis has gotten better,
but it's still too soon to say it's great.
Five years ago, you were lucky to make it to your twenties
with this disease.
So something to pay attention to.
Erb's palsy, brachial plexus.
Brachial plexopathy.
Typically, remember they won't be able
to move their shoulder.
We think of this oftentimes in shoulder dystocia
during birth, which is where we will see it
most of the time.
The infants mostly don't move their shoulder,
but they can move their fingers.
And we want to be able to reassure them,
if we think it's a stretch injury
because they have some movement in motion intact,
then it's really teaching the parents
how to manage physical therapy
and do physical therapy with their infant every day.
Here your congenital hand deformity.
So syndactyly is the most common congenital hand deformity.
Can be simple or complex.
That's clinical, that would not be on the exam,
but the syndactyly would be.
Polydactyly, you know, that's the extra digits.
The ones we ligate is if I have an ulnar,
an extra ulnar digit, then I ligate it.
But if I have an extra middle digit, I don't.
That's operative care for those.
Developmental dysplasia of the hip
and Dr. Bestie will talk
a little bit more about this with you,
but just to remind you, left hip is most common,
females, first born, breach position,
family history, and then any oligohydramnios.
So all these are risk factors for developmental dysplasia.
They're probably not gonna ask you
about Ortolani's and Barlow's maneuvers.
We use ultrasound now to make the diagnosis
and then follow these kids.
The Pavlik harness is what you want to utilize
in the first six months of life.
After that, you're gonna spike a cast them
because now they're sitting and getting ready to crawl.
Okay, so our first question,
which of the following statements is true
regarding bone tumors
in the pediatric and adolescent population?
Okay, D is the correct answer,
and we're gonna go over these, okay?
These are things that I do want you to know.
Osteosarcoma is the most common malignant bone tumor
in the adolescent pediatric population.
These are gonna be incidental findings.
You're gonna find it because the parent brings in the child
because they're having knee pain
or ankle pain or shoulder pain
and they don't have a good explanation for it.
There was no injury.
And you're gonna find an abnormal exam
typically by the time they bring them in, perhaps not.
You'll get a radiograph that'll lead you down the road
of further imaging, and then ultimately biopsy.
Ewing's sarcoma, the second most common,
not the most common.
Benign bone tumors, nonossifying fibromas.
These are benign. They're typically incidental findings.
You're getting a radiograph for some other reason.
And you see these typically in the distal femur
or distal tibia is where we most often will see them.
They tend to resolve with skeletal maturity.
Most of them are marginal.
They're around the cortex,
not necessarily intramedullary completely,
and they have sclerotic margins.
We'll talk about that. I'll show you a radiograph.
And then osteochondroma's are outgrowths of the bone
and they cause most of their pain and problems
because of soft tissue impingement.
Occasionally, well, I wouldn't say,
I would say early on
when you are considering an osteochondroma
you're gonna probably want to do some additional testing
and you may want to get a biopsy
because sometimes they're unclear.
It'll depend on what the testing shows.
But here on the left side, you see the NOF,
the nonossifying fibroma.
So it's marginal, it's near the cortex,
it has sclerotic margins.
That's typically what we see.
And over time, there's no reason to follow this.
I mean, it's gonna involute
and it's gonna calcify over time.
So there's no reason that you have to follow this,
but just know we make the diagnosis based on the radiograph.
And then on the right is what an osteochondroma looks like.
And so these have the potential.
Typically we'll get an MRI.
Sometimes we'll get a bone scan as well
that goes along with it.
We put those together to try and decide,
do we think this has some kind of question of a neoplasm
that it needs to be biopsied.
If not, then it's an osteochondroma
and the diagnosis is made.
But you see how they can cause soft tissue problems
because they're sort of sticking out
in areas that we don't want them.
Okay, our next question.
A 6-year-old female is brought to your office
for evaluation.
She was born at 39 and three seven weeks
by normal spontaneous vaginal delivery without complication.
She's met all of her orthopedic developmental milestones.
Her mother notes, she's been more clumsy at recess,
occasionally falling when running.
On exam, you note that her patellae point forward
or point inward, I'm sorry,
and her feet point inward
and there is no joint or limb tenderness or swelling.
Her neurological exam is normal.
So what is the most likely diagnosis?
Okay, femoral anteversion is the correct answer,
but the other half of you chose internal tibial torsion.
So we'll find out why you chose that, okay.
So when we look at this,
we really have three causes of intoeing.
The first is metatarsus adductus.
Most of these are mild,
most of them resolved by one to two years of age.
There's nothing that we do for them
short of just making the diagnosis.
Know that this is the most common
congenital foot abnormality, metatarsus adductus.
Second is internal tibial torsion.
And half of you probably chose this
because this is the most common cause of intoeing overall.
What do they like to ask you?
They like to ask you questions about,
and parents like to ask this,
maybe physical therapy would help,
or so and so wore a special orthotic shoes.
Or you know, what else can we do?
Is there a brace we can utilize?
The answer is no, no, no and no.
Just let them grow up with this,
because again, most cases are mild
and you're going to not make a decision about surgery
until somewhere between eight and 11 years of age.
And then our third cause of intoeing is femoral anteversion.
So in femoral anteversion, the patellae will point inward
when you quickly look at them where you watch their gait,
and their toes also point inward.
Whereas with internal tibial torsion,
the patellae point straightforward
and the toes point inward.
So you can oftentimes get a very quick assessment
simply by watching them walk.
That will become exaggerated when you actually
have them run down the hall toward you.
Again, they gotta be in shorts, you know,
or whatever so that you can see the lower extremity.
Okay, next question.
A 15-year-old male is brought to your office
for evaluation of a new limp.
He plays football as an offensive lineman
and noted onset after practice three days ago.
He has not been ill and had no recent immunizations.
His examination demonstrates that he's afebrile.
His pulse is 74, his height 72 inches, weight is 200 pounds.
He has an antalgic gait
and limited and painful range of motion in the left hip.
What is your presumptive diagnosis?
Good. And most of you got it.
Slip capital femoral epiphysis.
So remember with the finger,
we asked a couple questions back to back.
We are doing it with the hip.
The board loves hand questions.
The board loves pediatric hip questions.
You could get, when I last took my boards,
I think they had five or six pediatric hip questions on it.
So we're not talking one or two,
we're talking sort of series of questions.
Okay, so this is now a 7-year-old
brought to the emergency department
with right hip pain and a new limp.
Onset has been abrupt in the last 12 hours.
There's been no trauma or injury.
She's otherwise well and no recent illness or immunizations.
On exam, you know that she is,
has a temperature of 39.2 degrees centigrade,
normal respirations, pulse and blood pressure.
The right hip appears normal,
is painful with range of motion
and she limps with ambulation.
The hip radiographs are normal.
Which of the following is most useful
in determining your treatment plan?
Good. Most of you got D being the correct answer, right?
But my question is always, why?
Because you knew that that was really what you wanted
or you thought it gave you the most information.
This is a hard question and admittedly so,
but it's because the board likes a specific data set
and that's sometimes the case.
So let's look at these.
Transient synovitis is the most common
of these hip conditions that's gonna occur.
That's what we're gonna see most often.
Typically it's in that four to 11 year age range.
If the problem with this is if they're febrile
and a large portion of them will be febrile,
we have to discern is this septic,
or is this toxic synovitis or transient synovitis?
They mean the same thing.
Or is this a spontaneous or idiopathic
or otherwise hip abscess,
which also occurs in this age group but is much less common.
Okay?
Yes, they have painful gait as all of these do.
They have limited and painful range of motion.
And then we're gonna talk specifically about the data
on which tests that we're gonna get.
For slipped capital femoral epiphysis,
this is my younger teenagers, if you will,
male African Americans,
and those who are overweight and obese
are at highest risk for this.
If I have an acute SCFE, as in our question,
three days, I was fine,
three days ago after practice,
I noted that I started having pain.
That would be an acute situation.
If I have that, my risk of avascular necrosis is about 30%.
So those individuals, I want to call my orthopedic surgeon.
I want to say I've got, you know, a teenager here
with an acute SCFE.
I've got radiographs.
You want to take a look at the radiographs
and they're likely gonna say,
either send them to my office now
or admit them to the hospital.
We'll operate tomorrow, okay?
So you wanna move quickly on them
to reduce their risk of vascular necrosis.
If it's chronic, if it occurs over months,
you know, I've had this intermittent limb
and it kind of comes back and it gets a little bit worse,
those, they can be managed in a less acute fashion
because the risk of avascular necrosis is markedly less.
Legg-calve-perthes, think of this as basically
an avascular necrosis of the epiphysis of the forming hip,
which is why we see it primarily in toddlers.
If they're six years old, by the time we're diagnosing it,
they have a poor prognosis.
And what's the treatment for it?
You're gonna diagnose it right in your office.
I'll show you the radiograph.
They're gonna come in with an intermittent limp usually.
You might not catch it on the first radiograph
if you think about it.
So you may reassure the parent, send them home.
They may come back next month saying, Tommy's limping again.
You know, and you take a look at it.
Or Tommy's, you know,
rubbing his thigh all the time and limping, okay.
You repeat the radiograph
because you may not have seen it the first time.
Now it's developed a little bit more.
You're not changing the outcome or the prognosis.
It's a process that is gonna go on, if you will.
Okay, so here's slipped capital femoral epiphysis
on this left hip.
And so you can see how you've lost that contour
on the superior surface.
And then you see the overhang on the inferior surface.
And this is exactly what it looks like, okay?
You may want to know Drehmann sign.
So as you are trying to flex the hip, and I have a SCFE,
they're gonna move into external rotation.
So I'm not moving,
but as I'm trying to passively flex the hip,
the hip is gonna do this automatically.
I can't bring it straight up because the contours changed.
So this is the way the hip flexes.
That's called Drehmann sign.
If I have a young individual, so if they're less than 10,
then I'm gonna think about this a little bit differently.
Your orthopedic surgeon's gonna counsel them
probably on pinning both sides.
So treat the affected hip, but also treat the unaffected hip
because the risk of them having this develop
on that side is high
and the risk of it being acute is high.
So that means the risk of avascular necrosis is high.
That's a worse outcome than prophylactically treating
that hip per se.
And then the other consideration
is to screen these younger kids
if they develop it less than age 10
for thyroid and growth hormone, okay.
Here's legg-calve-perthes,
and this is just exactly what it looks like.
You see that flattening and fragmentation
of the femoral epiphysis on the left.
This was a 4-year-old.
This was the second time I saw the 4-year-old.
This was the second set of radiographs.
The first set were about,
I don't know, six to eight weeks earlier, looked normal.
This was the second set because I was concerned about it
and I counseled mom, bring him back if this happens again.
And she did. Okay, what's the treatment?
Referral to a pediatric orthopedist if you have that.
If you don't refer to an orthopedist,
and what are you gonna do in the meantime?
What's the orthopedist gonna do?
Gonna cast them, gonna put them in a wheelchair,
gonna put them in some kind of fancy brace.
Orthopedist is gonna say, okay, looks good.
Mom or dad, limit Johnny or Susie's or whoever's activity,
I'll see you back in a month or two months
and we'll repeat the X-rays.
So generally that's the treatment
you're gonna institute, right?
There can be surgical treatment,
but you're saying you call your orthopedic and say,
I have a kid that has legg-calve-perthes
and they say, yeah, yeah, okay.
Well don't you want to see them right away?
Oh yeah, whenever they get on the schedule is fine with me.
Well, what am I supposed to tell them in the meantime?
Well tell them quit running around.
So that's the information that you give.
But that's essentially the treatment
is we try and limit the activity.
We try and limit weightbearing activity.
We do not immobilize them,
we do not put them in wheelchairs, nothing of the sort.
So you just try and limit their overall activity.
Okay, we said we were gonna come back to this.
How do I sort this out between transient synovitis
and a septic hip?
Well, this is something that you wouldn't
probably otherwise know unless you're doing this regularly.
But this is Kochers data
and this is something that's somewhat unique to our board.
They like this data. They ask questions about this data.
If I'm trying to discern the difference between
does my patient have transient synovitis of the hip
or do they have a septic hip?
Then I'm gathering this data.
What's their weight bearing status?
What's their temperature?
What's their white blood cell count?
What's their sedimentation rate.
And what's their c-reactive protein.
I take that data and I put it together.
And if I have more than three,
if I have four or five that are positive,
then I wanna ultrasound that hip
and probably gonna aspirate it.
The reason I don't just go straight to an ultrasound
is most of these kids will have some joint fluid in there.
So that doesn't really help me.
That's why the hip hurts in the first place.
The capsule and the synovium are reactive
and so they produce some fluid.
And so I have an effusion in that hip anyway.
I'm trying to decide,
do I need to stick a needle in it or not?
Do I need to then start treating this child or not?
Do I need to admit them to the hospital or not?
So there's a whole process that's involved with this.
But anyway, this is the data they like.
If I have one or two that are positive
and the rest are negative, I'm not gonna do anything.
I'll reassure them.
I'll probably see them back in 24 hours
and see how they're doing.
Okay, next question.
A 12-year-old male was brought in for evaluation
of his right elbow pain.
He's a pitcher on his middle school baseball team.
Onset was insidious,
occurred about three weeks into the baseball season,
is aggravated by throwing and relieved by rest.
He's noted decreased velocity and accuracy of his pitches.
On exam, you note tenderness at the right medial epicondyle.
You conclude the following.
A, this is a lateral epicondylar stress fracture.
B, this is an apophysitis.
C, this is golfer's elbow.
D, this is tennis elbow.
Okay good. This is an apophysitis.
So you know, just like we talked about overuse injuries,
the apophysitis are overuse injuries, if you will,
but they just affect the pediatric population.
Remember the apophysis is not the physis, right?
The physis is a growth center for lengthening a bone.
The apophysis, we call a secondary ossification center
because it's just bone and bone uniting.
They're just growing together, okay?
Nothing's being elongated. They're simply fusing together.
It's taking the site
where a major tendon inserts on the bone
and fusing that to the underlying bone.
Where that fusion occurs is called the apophysis.
So the patellar tendon, the tibial tubercle,
I have an apophysis where the tibial tubercle
is going to ultimately attach to the tibia.
The achilles attaches to the calcaneal apophysis,
which which eventually is gonna attach to
or grow to the calcaneus so that they attach.
That's what we refer to as the apophysis.
So in this population, I have these,
think of the apophysis as the weak link, all right?
And then think about what we talked about
in terms of overuse injury.
I have repetitive activity that I start somewhat suddenly.
Okay, I start a new sport, I start gym class.
At recess, we're practicing running now or jump roping
or whatever it might be.
So we're doing a lot of that all at once.
And I have limited time for recovery.
Now in probably most of your populations,
that means that the child is going to soccer
on Monday and Tuesday and Thursday,
maybe doing gymnastics on Wednesday and Friday
and you know, maybe playing with their friends or something
on Saturday, okay?
Doesn't have to be the same activity,
but it's enough of the same repetitive actions, okay?
These are clinical diagnoses.
Do not fall for the trick of getting imaging
in order to make your diagnosis.
They're clinical diagnoses. Okay?
So this case was little league elbow pitching.
Typically the middle school pitcher,
anywhere from three to five weeks into the season,
they're throwing too much.
They start developing this medial elbow pain.
The pitching accuracy, velocity, et cetera,
all starts to fall off
and they come in to tell you about that.
And when you examine them,
you find tenderness at the medial epicondyle
because I have an epiphysis at that site
for my wrist flexors, okay?
That's the weak link in the chain.
So what do we do with these individuals?
In this specific case, we stop all their throwing
for three to six weeks until all their pain resolves.
And then we start them on a rehabilitative program.
So with physical therapy, typically not their coaches,
typically a physical therapist
and they start a rehabilitative throwing program.
That's gonna take another three to six weeks
for them to be able to do that.
And then they can gradually return to activity.
You also need to know that major league baseball
has put out some preventive measures
and you need to know what these are.
Four months of rest per year.
No use of radar guns.
And people need to avoid being pitcher and catcher.
They can't play both positions. It's one or the other.
They're the only two positions in baseball
that handle the ball every single play, okay?
But I want you to also realize that
there's a bit of nomenclature here
that can become a little tricky.
Medial epicondylar apophysitis.
And don't confuse that with little league.
That's little league elbow.
Don't confuse that with little league shoulder
because they're entirely different.
And you're gonna have to know the difference between the two
because you'll see them as potential answers multiple times.
So you need to know what each one is.
Little league shoulder is a proximal humeral epiphysitis,
not apophysitis, epiphysitis.
So think of it as a stress fracture
of the growth plate, right?
So little league shoulder,
stress fracture of the growth plate.
Little league elbow, it's an apophysitis at the elbow
involving two completely different structures.
So why is that important?
Well, if I have a stress structure of the growth plate,
that's gonna affect growth.
Whereas if I have an overuse injury of the apophysis,
that's just gonna cause more pain, all right,
but it's not gonna affect growth.
So you need to be able to discern the difference
between the two of these.
Okay, question six.
An 11-year-old male is brought to your office
for evaluation of bilateral posterior heel pain
that occurred for the past few months.
He plays basketball and soccer several times a week
and the pain begins several minutes
into each of these activities.
There is no pain with rest or walking.
He denies numbness, tingling, or weakness.
On exam, you find no swelling or tenderness
of the heel or achilles tendon.
Reflexes, strength and range of motion
at the ankle are intact.
But he does have bilateral posterior heel pain
when you passively and fully dorsi flex the ankles.
So the question is,
which of the following is the most likely diagnosis?
Plantar fasciitis, Severs disease,
heel pad syndrome, or Achilles tendonopathy.
Okay, good. Severs disease.
So this is an apophysitis.
Here's a table that you can look at,
the ones that, for those of you who are taking the exam,
the ones to really pay attention to are
Osgood Schlatter's and Severs to know those.
But the others are common ones that we run into.
And common ones that you've probably seen
in your office as well.
Pelvic avulsion fractures, just to mention these,
really common in sprinting sports,
you know, sports that require stopping and starting.
And you get this forceful muscle contraction
and you just, you're pulling this bone,
these are apophysis and you're just pulling the bone
away from the underlying bone.
And this is the pelvis.
So it's anterior superior iliac spine,
anterior inferior iliac spine.
It could be the iliac crest and the ischial tuberosity.
So these are all places that you can just pull the bone
away from the other underlying bone.
You're gonna treat these just like you would a fracture.
It's always gonna be crutches
'cause they're incredibly painful.
We're not thinking about surgery,
even though the recommendations are,
if you have two centimeters of displacement,
you ought to surgically fix it, I've never done that.
I've never seen anybody do it.
We talk about it at meetings all the time.
Nobody's ever done it. They heal regardless.
So you put them on crutches
and let them weight bear as tolerated.
In pediatric ACL injuries,
it's important that once you diagnose a pediatric ACL tear,
if that child has another episode of instability
in that knee, they are causing additional damage, okay?
So pediatric ACL injuries,
if they have another episode of instability,
if their knee gives out on them
after they've ruptured the ACL,
you need to push towards reconstruction
because they're continuing to damage that knee.
And you can do an ACL repair.
You know, there was a big push
about these physeal sparing techniques
that were being done for ACL repair
so that we didn't interrupt growth in individuals.
For the most part, the biggest group that's affected
is 12 to 16.
It becomes a non-issue at that point in time
because for the most part, their vertical growth is done
and there has not been good documentation
that it has in fact interrupted growth.
So they go ahead and get repaired.
Idiopathic scoliosis, I don't want you to focus much on this
other than you know,
to realize that there's infantile juvenile
and adolescent idiopathic scoliosis.
And know that for adolescent idiopathic scoliosis,
USPSTF has changed their recommendation,
from a recommendation to screen
to a recommendation of insufficient evidence, okay?
For adolescent idiopathic scoliosis.
Okay, and our last question here.
Pediatric obesity is associated
with each of the following, except.
Is it impaired mobility, an overall lower risk of fracture,
longer fracture healing times,
or higher risk of surgical complications
for fracture repair.
Okay, so yes, pediatric obesity, impaired mobility, yes.
They have longer fracture healing times, yes.
They're more likely to require surgical intervention
for their fracture than those who are non-obese.
They're more likely to end up in the ICU after surgery
than the non-obese.
They're more likely to have a DVT post-surgery
Complications.
More likely to have low back pain, arthritis,
SCFE, you are already aware of that, et cetera.
So all of these are associated with obesity
in the pediatric and adolescent population.
And that's it. Thank you.
Thank you very much, Dr. Gary.
(soft music)